greetings [__] uncle joey's joint
is brought to you by lucy nicotine gum
listen
it's december everybody's making their
[__] uh
i'm quitting this i'm not gonna eat pie
i'm not gonna stab midgets no more all
that [__]
whatever the [__] those things are
called you also gotta quit smoking
uh it's one of the things that covert
will hit and [__] grow it
but besides that you just gotta quit
smoking for your [__] health okay
and i got something for you to help you
lucy nicotine gum
i quit smoking years ago i still [__]
around with the gum because it gives me
a little joke
i usually get a [__] name brand if
you see i got no lucy
products because i [__] ate them all
they were fantastic
i'm waiting on the next shipment you
know because when you're craving the
smoke
you just need a little something to
satisfy the habit
that's why i let i love lucy gum i love
all the [__] flavors the winter green
the cinnamon but my favorite is
pomegranate if you're looking to quit
smoking and you're [__] serious
and you need all the help you can
because sometimes you need the patch
you need the cigarette for the sensation
you need the gum for the sensation to
kill that
this is the way the [__] start lucy
nicotine gum so do me a favor
the [__] uncle joints family go to
lucy
dot co c o that's it knock dot com
go lucy dot co and use promo code
joey to get 20 percent off all products
including gum and they've got lozenges
that's lucy dot co and use promo code
joey also i gotta give you this
disclaimer
the product contains nicotine derived
from tobacco
nicotine is an addictive chemical just
go to lucy.com
and be sure to use promo code joey
okay don't forget what i'm telling you
it's time to [__] quit smoking
go to lucy dot co use promo code joey
and get this program started
you're going to thank me in a [__]
year you're going to [__] send me a
tweet and go joe you're a genius
i'm not smoking doug no more but i'm
doing heroin what's the [__]
difference
oh jokes aside lucy dot co
use promo code joey the joint is also
brought to you by
on it listen you're looking for
christmas presents for people
you got a [__] cousin who's a little
[__] you know he's not cooking on
all cylinders
alpha brain comes in right there why not
take a chance columbus did
this is the last thing you got before
you hit him in the head with a [__]
hammer
and alpha brain also comes in a powder
you mix it with water shake it up
boom just in case you don't like pills
also shroom tech i know you got a lot of
athletes
and your family hey give them the gift
of [__] health
shroom tech immune schum tech sports
kettlebells
on it's got it all club bats [__]
maces
they got everything i can't give you a
discount on that
but i got you on the supplements have
you tried the melatonin yet
from [__] on it have you tried the
coconut almond chocolate protein bar
bites yet from honey no so this is what
i'm telling you
makes a great christmas present and you
get your mind going a lot of people
don't have focus
this is the way to start alpha brain i'm
telling you right now
i started my cycle night but a complete
different person
i'm clear i'm focused and i know what i
[__] want you understand me
so it starts today go to honor.com right
now
and press encode church c-h-u-r-c-h
and get 10 percent off delivered to your
house it's that [__] easy
let's start the month off on a good
[__] leg here
and that's it go to honor.com and press
in church and get 10 percent off
delivered to your house
and if you're looking to quit cigarettes
lucy dot co
is the way to go try the pomegranate
gum let's get this [__] party started
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
welcome to uncle joey's joint
it's monday december 12th we made
another [__] weekend
and uh we're [__] here uh i give
a lot of uh i'm sorry to the residents
my former neighbors
in la they shut you down started
yesterday
right back to where we were in [__]
march
no playgrounds no [__] restaurants
no [__] nothing and my heart goes out
to you
uh you know lockdown is eminent here
also but
for right now we'll have everything open
the schools so we're running with gas
but my heart goes out to you guys
like i said i wasn't uh i'm a ged
[__] i got sick and tired of
being the smartest [__] guy in the
room
something was in the air and something
told me to get the [__] out of there i
i can't imagine what my family would be
like right now if we were still there
but
i'm giving thanks to being the [__] out
of there and i'm uh just letting you
guys know in california
i did not forget about you i love you
[__] with all my heart
it was just uh time to go and when it's
time to go
it's time to go you got no time to be
[__] around or giving hugs
and saying goodbye you know i don't know
what's going on with numbers
i don't know nothing about transmission
rates i just know i
mind my [__] business and that's it
and that's that but anyway enough with
that talk you guys get enough of that
talk whole [__] day
everywhere you go that's all that's on
people's minds
i'm here to take your mind off that for
an hour 45 minutes whatever the [__] i
talk to until i get a [__] headache
and i'm sick of goddamn talking but uh
you know
the base of this podcast is the youth
you know sometimes i forget i think when
i started this
when we started doing uncle joey's joint
i forgot that the youth concept
was so very [__] important of this
the people that watch this aren't 50
year old
they're out there [__] doing that
thing it's young kids
it's kids that are lost kids that got
their [__] together
but want more it's so weird i i read
emails on all the genres you know
i get emails on twitter i get emails on
facebook
i get emails on patreon and it's the
same group
it's the same age group that really is
struggling the most right now and it's
the kids in their [__] 20s
and listen man it's just tough being in
your [__] 20s let's start with that
it's got nothing to do with you god
didn't hand pick you
society isn't picking on you being in
your 20s
sucks whether you're in college
whether you're not in college and you're
trying to figure it out
whether you took a year off to [__]
go to india
and get bit in the [__] neck by a
snake whatever the [__] you decide to do
you decide to do
now a lot of years are like joey we
don't know what the next step
is the next step usually when you're in
your 20s
is hitting rock bottom in a way like
you're not going to end up a bum with
dirt on your face and people throwing
dirt on you
you hit rock bottom somewhere
emotionally
and for me that was the [__] case
like i just
you know for me if i have to narrow it
down again
the other day i was always over here
spitting out dates about december
and i said something about december 12th
maybe ozzy's birthday and then
you guys correct me with the third blah
blah blah blah
and i got my dates confused you know
it's it's amazing how
life comes back to bite you in the
[__] ass with certain dates the
reason why i said december 12th was
that's the day i became homeless in
1984.
you know and uh when i when we when mike
left and
the podcast was done and i had to do
some other [__] around here
i i don't know i went and got gas and i
thought about why i said december 12th
and i was like [__] that wasn't ozzie's
birthday that's not a
[__] whatever that's the day i got i
became officially homeless
until new year's eve i was homeless
until about new year's eve week
and then i got myself a hotel room for a
few nights some [__]
you know you're scratching from the
crabs type of hotel
and then my ex-teacher took me in and my
life changed in 85
it was the breather that that changed me
but i still remember walking into that
park every night
you know uh and this week it got colder
here in new jersey
the weather dropped that night and i
would go outside to take a walk to smoke
a joint
because my daughter's around and
for some reason december 12th came back
to me that oh
what i was going through in my [__]
life how frustrated i was
i was basically homeless because i was a
[__] junkie
i put the junk before myself which is uh
what happens it's funny i was watching
the uh
from your recommendation a lot of guys
told me to watch the heck the matcha
camacho
documentary on showtime and saturday
night it just happened to [__] be on
i'm sorry about the sirens it's not that
the cops are looking for me is that
santa claus is coming to town
so a bunch of kids are out chasing fire
trucks right now
looking for santa but it's funny how
he set a line at the end they called him
a champion he goes i'm not really a
champion
i'm a junkie first and then i'm a
that [__] line resonated with me
because
i for years i considered myself a junkie
once you come to terms
with what the [__] you are we live in
denial you living tonight you're like ah
you know it's okay if i do [__] eight
grams of coke a week that's accepted
you know that's how i was living which
is [__] denial you know
and uh just
being in that rocket ship you know i
would have to walk into a park
walk past the swings walk past a see-saw
there were these little [__] animals
that you get on you ever see those
things with the coil on the bottom
i had to walk around them and then i had
to go to the rocket ship
and with like a pint of booze in my
jacket
and my scarf and my hood i would climb
up the little [__] ladder all the way
to the third floor
and i would just shiver and drink the
vodka and cry
because that's what [__] do they cry
when they blame the world
and i would blame wise have this going
on with me
the world hates me god put a curse on me
and then at the end of the vlog i tried
to jerk off outside
and i'd [__] pass out in the [__]
third floor
and i'd wake up in the morning and it
was like three weeks of that
for three weeks i lived that [__]
life of just
telling my friends i'm gonna stay at my
other buddy's house whoo
a guy on 88th street i became friends
with and they would drop me off and i
would go into this rocket ship
but when i was sitting in that rocket
ship
i knew this had to change i knew that
was my rock bottom
i knew that there was only one
other thing under this that would
that i could go and i was dying i was
just gonna die outside i thought i was
gonna die outside
but i got that hudson county water in me
that [__]
uh you know hudson river water in me it
kept me [__] alive
and i would fall asleep outside in the
[__] wind i didn't even wake up with
my hand
well his fingers are frozen you're gonna
get hypothermia no
there was no hypothermia there was
nothing i woke up
i walked around i did what i had to do
but
being in that rocket ship flip something
it switched something it was for me like
going you know we were talking about
getting called out by your friends here
that's a life call out you know that's
when life [__] calls you out
there was no place to go i mean uh here
i am in this [__] rocket ship
i couldn't go to anybody i had worn out
all my welcomes all over north bergen
i was done you know that's it i had put
myself in this [__] position
but i [__] snapped like something
just [__] snapped
and the same way i built the blueprint
to come back here
and do the levels of things i got to do
this first
i got to get the podcast going first i
got i took my life
the same [__] way and it worked you
know one day i was hanging out outside
in front of a bar
two in the afternoon who's at a bar at
two in the afternoon
homeless people alcoholics that's who
goes to a bar at two in the afternoon
and i'm at this bar watching soap operas
with a bunch of [__] losers
and i go outside to just like smoke pot
or something
and i saw one of my [__] teachers and
one of my teachers that was cool
and i went up to him and he's like you
know i'll get you know rehab blah blah
blah
and i called him and there was no room
at the rehab and all this [__] i ended
up staying with him
i ended up staying with him from january
1st of 85
to towards the maybe the end of uh
february
and it gave me two months to really
think i was clean
i was just smoking pot i wasn't drinking
i wasn't doing any pills no cocaine i
was
actually clean and that was the first
time in my life
in 1985 at the age of 23
that i was officially on my own i was
off
life's [__] umbilical cord
you know there was no mom there was no
dad
there was no friends i was living with
crescal
20 miles away from where i'm from and i
was just putting my life together on my
own
he had an attic he put me up and he had
two other kids
one dear friends with today nicholas and
christopher
that big time is today they both work
for you know
[__] nicholas works for like cbs or
something like that constantly contacts
me
and at that time i was a good kid i just
was confused
like a lot of you guys what the [__] is
my next step
you know uh i had already done a couple
but was and i had already done a couple
credits of college
at colorado mountain college you know i
had all this [__] going on
and i lost it all for drugs for [__]
to do coke do that i had this thing in
my mind i was like [__]
i i i don't even know i have no idea
where to start and when and with
what the [__] was going through my mind
but
living with mr t and his family and the
kids and seeing
it let me know what i wanted uh
what i didn't want to do you know i
didn't stop being a criminal
my criminal lies was still [__] there
but one day t came to me like a man that
he is and he goes hey man
you've been here for two months and you
haven't overstayed your welcome your
family
but i feel it's time for you to get an
apartment and take the steps
to make it [__] happen and he goes
you got like another week to stay here
i'm not throwing you out
but it's time it's time for you to go
out there and go into the real world
and it hurt a little bit it hurt a
little bit
but i understood what he was doing
and i you know uh i got my i moved into
like a men's home
in [__] tenta fly new jersey and then
i was there for like two weeks and they
found
[__] i was smoking pot in front of
the building and the lady got mad
and then i ended up in another house
that a lady owned and
three guys lived upstairs you know her
family was gone her kids had gone to
college
and she didn't want to live alone i just
basically lived in flop houses you know
75 a week you get a bedroom and you got
to share a bathroom with people that's
what i was doing that 20 [__] three
you know i was just living in flop
houses and then one day
i [__] uh the lady had a son and
i saw him in the daytime and he got high
and him and i went and smoked pot
together
and uh he had this jewelry and he goes
you know if you could help me sell it
and i ended up getting arrested that's
not the point of the story
but just you know letting you know that
i was i still was not
dorothy wasn't out of the [__] woods
dorothy was not in the woods and then
the dad got arrested i bumped into our
friend george who
uh i had him on the church towards the
end when i had my friends on and
i talked about him dearly all the time
because
george saved my life i just happened to
bump into him
i got arrested that night and when i
called him
to bail me out uh he took the extra step
and said
not only am i bailing you out but you're
moving with me and my family and that
really helped me out a lot it helped me
out
on the emotional side because i thought
that god had given up
i thought that the world had given up on
me but that wasn't the case this one guy
still cared about me and i didn't smack
him in the face i
i slept on this floor and i [__]
got a construction job and he'll tell
you he'll tell you i was not snorting
coke i was not going out at night
i was really trying to keep my [__]
life together
and then i got a call that i had a
settlement over his shoulder
they gave me 18 grand was waiting for me
and i uh
i decided to go to colorado and
when i left to colorado in june of 85
i was still cleaning off the cocaine i
wasn't drinking
i was just smoking pot was i doing
criminal activities
yes stupid [__] that's when i was
robbing the gas stations
i was doing under the limit [__] so i
couldn't couldn't get caught
you know i would rob [__] businesses
i would
walk into a building and rob businesses
i was doing a bunch of
uh a stupid ship it was basically credit
card debt
i was a one-man [__] wrecking crew
i mean you know mondays is travelers
checks
tuesdays with credit cards wednesday was
a gas station
thursday was ripping off a building you
know and i'm am i proud of these things
no
but they happened and i can't change who
the [__] i am i can't change it now it's
too [__] late
in fact it's a part of who i am today i
mean if i sit here obviously and go
wow if i could do my [__] life over
what could i do over you know
nothing nothing that there's nothing i
could do over
because i wouldn't be in this position
today to talk like you
to you like this about life or any other
[__] situation
i didn't go to you know i would have
loved to get an mba from harvard
i would have loved to get a law degree
from [__] stanford or something like
that
but that's not what was in the cards for
me you know i
might what people don't understand about
me was my dream
wasn't to become a [__] comic
my dream was to become a man a
productive
person of society somebody who you know
helps
little old ladies across the street and
don't rob them and
you know helps people shovel snow and
that was my thing from the beginning
this just that
this dream did not start out for me to
be a
grandioso comic and be at the comedy
store
it didn't it didn't at all this dream
was about me being
a [__] just a good guy a human being
you know
being able to earn people's respect not
having people looking at me
like i i did go to prison you know all
the time like that guy can't be trusted
you know women would see me and they
would move their purses
you know [__] like that i i didn't want
to live that life anymore i didn't want
to be that person
i just wanted to be a [__] human
being and
you know i say to you guys you know when
people
call you out on different things for me
it was mr t
for me it was you know mr blue at the
[__] halfway house for me it was uh
you know matt woods the comic who turned
my comedy career around
you know when i was from from 15
to 23 i was just like you guys
let's face it i answered an email the
other day some guys like
you know thank you for uh doing all the
music stuff
i try to influence my son with it but he
won't
refuse to um uh comprehend it he doesn't
really
and i'm like listen people gotta come
around on their own
you're not gonna lead a horse to drink
[__] water
they're gonna do everything on their own
that flip that switch has to flip within
your own
you know when you guys hit me up on an
email
no matter what it is no matter what it
could be
you know on any subject on abroad not a
on
going to school on you know doing drugs
or whatever
uh i see a lot of me and you guys at
that age
which is just confusion we just don't
know we just don't know who the [__] to
ask
you know the person that loves you the
most which is probably in your case your
[__] parents
you know your grandfather maybe you have
an uncle i i don't know what the [__]
your house situation is but when they
sit you down when you're a young man
and they give you advice listen i didn't
take it either
i didn't take it either and that's why i
ended up homeless
do you see what i'm saying so when you
don't take advice
from people when you you know more than
them which
listen i was that guy i'm not here
faulting you
i know plenty of people still today that
they don't give a [__] what you tell
them even though they come and seek the
advice from you
they still won't listen they're going to
do it their way anyway
and you don't yell at them you don't get
mad then you just go god bless them
they thought it was a better way let's
see who has the better way
when they fail or whatever you don't rub
it in their face
you pull them aside and you go you know
this is why i talked to you
and said that you should have done it
this way this is the same thing that
happened to me you know there's just
little [__] things
when you go on patreon and you want to
write a blog
if you write a blog and you're going to
post a video about the blog
how much of a nightmare is it mike it
ain't going to happen
you got to post a blog you got to post a
video up first
so the [__] thing could go off i
don't know why i don't even know why i
brought
patreon up and anything like that but
it's the same thing with life
you got to do one thing before it does
the other if you want to do
you want to try your way i'm not mad at
you
go for it but you're gonna end up in the
same situation i was
on the third floor of a [__] rocket
ship looking out
you know i get people who complain to me
about their parents all the time
my parents get mad at me while you're
under their roof
you got to do what the [__] they say you
don't like what they say you want to
smoke weed in your room with your feet
up
get your own [__] place but you're
mad at them
because they're telling you you can't do
something
get your own [__] place it's time to
cut the [__] umbilical cord
and see what life is all about get the
[__] off that computer
get the [__] off that computer listen i
know you're probably doing work right
now you're typing
you're on your thing and you put the
podcast on just to listen
to be entertained while you're doing
something besides i don't mind you
[__] being on the computer but to be
on the computer 12
15 [__] hours a day i know at the end
of my week i have a thing on my computer
that comes up
that tells me how many hours i've been
on the computer if your time went up on
the computer
if your time has been low on the
computer guess what my time is getting
lower and lower on the [__] computer
i don't have the desire i used to have
going through all the [__]
social networks no one because it's all
the same [__] [__] anymore
you're not getting from facebook where
you were getting i see things on
facebook i
i saw a post i think saturday a chick
compared
louis ck to somebody else and
and i looked at the thread and i tried
to read it and i'm like
and austin they're throwing politics in
and i forget who she compared to
louisiana and then louis ck was all
right
but the guy who it's just it's just
nonsense
if you're finding relief on [__]
facebook
if that's what you want to do on and it
had 25
000 [__] people on there arguing
about louis ck and some [__] guy that
jerked off on the
phone you know when the [__] does it end
when the [__] does it end you know you
learn
a lot on the computer you learn how to
do this you know mike works on the
computer he does flyers he does this
but mike also has two [__] kids he's
racing
so it's not like he's on the [__]
computer all [__] day
you know during this [__] pandemic
whatever the [__] is going on
every time you sit in front of the
computer
the tv you know some outlet some guy
listening you know
this is why i don't want to bring up all
the negative [__] that's going on around
this right now
because as a matter of fact all this
negative [__] could be going on around
you
as long as you stay positive it's like a
snowstorm right when the snowstorm
[__] is coming down
what do you do sit there with your mouth
open and wait for the snowflakes to walk
in your [__] mouth no
you keep [__] walking it's a horrible
snowstorm there's winds going
your [__] ears are flapping you're
walking sideways you haven't been that
[__] windy
when you're walking [__] sideways you
know and what do you do dude you don't
just stand there
and let the [__] keep [__] fall on
you until you become [__] frosty
snowman you keep [__] walking and
that's what's going on right now
yes there's a thousand things going on
yes you're waiting for uh
i've been on the phone all day with
unemployment yeah but you could have
been chopping somebody's [__] wood
and made a hundred [__] dollars
meanwhile you're on the phone i i i'm
counting on employment listen
you're gonna call from until saint
general's day there's a window for
[__] unemployment
like two hours from six to eight and
then you're [__] on delay and you go
try to hustle something
the wink is coming i know they got eight
inches in boston
trust me lee was [__] mad because he
had a shovel i got inches
that was part of his [__] patreon
little workout was shelling 8 inches
you know you need money go shovel
[__] snow but it's a lot better than
sitting there
waiting for an employment to send you
that [__] check that by the time you
get ooh
i had a buddy every time i talk to him
i'm over here waiting for an employment
i'm over here i ain't find employment
dog i got here in august he just got the
check two [__] weeks ago
he could have done 20 [__] things in
those two months and he was waiting for
unemployment
i told him come down here paint the wall
[__] the cut of grass nothing he
didn't want to do nothing
so he had to wait in his [__]
apartment for two months for an
unemployment check
you can't be lazy the blue bird of
happiness has copied i don't know if you
know that
even the blueberry the happiness tested
for [__] cobin
all those people the [__] people that
used to bring the check to your door
remember hi
you want a million dollars they quit
they got covered too
they ain't dropping off any guinness on
nobody's house nobody's doing dick for
you
if you ain't doing it yourself now it's
going to be
and i love these people 2021
is going to be a better year we think
you know wake up january 1st
and a [__] bird is going to come up
to you and bring you like a note
covert is over no no
this is gonna go on till [__] in
september
be prepared get your [__] stock ready
work on yourself
this is the time this is what this is
for
this is what this is for ever since i
watched that [__] showtime
documentary on the comedy store
i've been trying to figure out what
[__] happened the last 20 years
that's what i've been trying ever since
i watched that documentary
and mess with my head in a way i can't
describe
because it i had asked myself
where have i been the last 20 [__]
years
and it was it was great it was a great
part of my life
it was like being in the nba you know
it was more than i ever anticipated
but guess what it's over now
it lives in my [__] head and i put it
in the back the same way when i went to
prison
the same way from when i was married the
same way
from when i was doing coke
it just goes in the [__] history
books
for me it's never gonna happen again i
wish the comedy store stays open
i wish the laugh factory stay is open i
wish all the improv stay open
i wish all the comedy clubs denver
comedy works
kansas city my man over in columbus
i hope they stay open but the sad
fact is a lot of comedy clubs we're
gonna hear
we're gonna be hearing about a lot of
comedy closings
a lot of venues that you grew up on
that you went to concerts at small
mom-and-pop theaters
you you're gonna be here and then 10 10
20 days
you know 10 20 days all these businesses
are going to be closing
especially out in california you just
cut out
our tourist season you know uh
yesterday or the day before or friday a
memory popped up
of me pushing mercy on a swing on
facebook
that was 2015. every year i would come
every other year me and my wife would
come
to new york this time of the year from
the
third to second to the sixth to seventh
because it's the cheapest it's gonna be
it's the cheapest
the hotels are empty the city's still
empty give it a [__] week
people go over there to see that [__]
tree people flying from
all over the world to see that [__]
tree well guess what
that's not happening this year that's
just not [__] happening
that's 80 percent of your [__] income
is what you make in december from
tourism
la the rose bowl and if you've noticed
they're going to open up on the 21st
which will help because that means those
rose bowlers come to town
when those guys come to town the 25th
they start rolling on the 26th of
december
[__] la is packed universal cities
packed the comedy stores packed
both teams in the rose bowl come to the
improv one night
so one night it's penn state the other
night it's the other team
you know this is big with everything
closed what are they going to do what's
the tourism
how many of these businesses are going
to handle just that [__] loss from do
you have any businesses depend on
december
do you have any [__] idea and you're
there in your house
complaining about uh-uh i gotta sit on
the computer
that was a day in work really that's
what you're complaining about you better
be [__] lucky you better get up every
morning
and go on your hands and knees like i do
and give thanks that i have a way
to earn a little bit of [__] money
you know i'm not on the road and then
the road
what do you think it's just going to
clean open in january
and people are going to be running down
and it's not going to happen but i made
the adjustment
i'm happy i'm happier if you look at me
you're like joey you look happy
you lost a little weight no i haven't
i'm about the same but
i'm cleaning up i'm going to the gym
[__] four days a week
i'm eating better i'm [__] definitely
sleeping
i'm definitely [__] sleeping a lot
better
i don't have that [__] around me
anymore
that [__] is dead you know my wife
on saturday
rented out a little play zone they have
close by
and uh my daughter and some of our
little girlfriends you know the parents
that have welcomed us
my wife wanted to you know give back
so my wife rented the little room at the
play zone
and got like i don't know how much money
and little [__]
passes and we have like [__] 12
little kids over there
yesterday you know from her class like
kids that go to her class
uh two of the girls from up the corner
and it was i think 10 girls and two
little boys
and the two little boys only showed up
because they were brothers
to the girls you should have seen their
faces when they had to take the picture
by the christmas tree at the end they
were like
really we got to take a picture with 10
little seven-year-old eight-year-old
girls
but
my wife said you know she you were
sitting there for a second and you
weren't playing any games towards the
end why
you know because i'm like marlon brando
i was just sitting there
taking it all in looking at these
parents
and the difference between the parents
that i was running with in los
angeles and the parents that i'm running
with here
the parents that i'm running with them
that i was running with from los angeles
they were nice people i have nothing
against them
i miss them dearly but their parenting
skills
and their yearning to be a parent was
not
the [__] parents i deal with here the
parents i deal with here first of all
they were very appreciative you know it
was a saturday
it was raining out most [__] wasn't
going
on and he and my wife put this little
thing together they made gingerbread
houses
do you think i made a gingerbread house
as a [__] kid
whatever they made gingerbread houses
then they went they played they had
[__] uh what's when you put the
shields on and you think you're a
[__] alien and [__]
mental reality without a [__] virtual
reality metro reality
uh they had all that [__] they played
[__]
space invaders they shot basketballs
they played uh what's that human
shuffleboard [__]
where they all had it was tremendous a
little girl got kicked in the head with
a ball
listen it didn't matter i was looking at
them and going wow
look at the difference of parenting the
parents were involved
they were like talking to me about how
they called a school every [__] day
and torment the principal they got his
cell phone number
they got his emails they [__] blast
him
you know these are you know why i lived
in california parents were like well
they closed this phone what are you
gonna do
these [__] are [__] you open up
the [__] school
you [__] savage you [__] animal so
it's just
you know i i was just taking in what
what the [__] did i come from i can't
you know i i told my wife i go
i feel bad because i didn't lie to you
that is the craziest thing everything i
told you new jersey was
it is i never lied to you about any
about this stuff
whether it was the [__] food i mean
yesterday the place brought in like
pizza
like part of the deal comes in with
pizza and i remember i was like i'm not
gonna waste weight
watch your points ate on some [__]
pizza
and the neighbor my man frank from
across the street is from staten island
he's got two kids he's missed the
[__] the pizza sucks around here
he came out he goes this pizza is not
bad i go frank how many times are gonna
[__] tell you bad pizza in jersey
is better than good pizza in california
i go it's not bad let me get a [__]
slice
i tasted it it was [__] delicious
delicious and the crust was burnt a
little
weird like it was higher than regular
pizza
like they actually burnt them it was
crispy and it had a weird taste to it
[__] tremendous i go you know on the
way home my wife grossed me out even the
[__] pizza was good
in fact we heated up and he ate it for
dinner last night that's how good it was
that's not my point the point is that
all these things i felt in my head
before i left california
were real new jersey does have so much
more to offer
food-wise people-wise parent-wise
the behavior in kids i saw in l.a and
the behavior here listen my wife saw
a [__] at the park maybe two weeks
ago like when we were in l.a we'd see
bad kids doing [__]
in their parents you just go like hahaha
you know he's so
you know he's creative and he doesn't
know how to
process his energy your kids a punk
little [__]
and he's gonna end up sucking dicks if
you don't step in the middle of this
right now look him
look at him he's half a [__]
fruitcake already with ballerina's shoes
on
and you're talking about you don't know
how to [__] how he should push his
energy well
let me tell you something here my wife
saw a [__] lady
smack a little boy in the face at the
park
my wife's like the parenting here they
don't [__] around i guess the little boy
went and smacked the mother
at the park she goes to mother even
hesitate
as the kid's hand was going down she was
already up
giving him a cross smack to the face and
then told him to pack up his toys he was
[__] going home
and to never touch him again and my wife
even came home was like
holy [__] it's a different [__]
animal here it's a different
[__] animal compared to what i was
but the whole point of the story
was that you know
we made a decision we moved on
nothing a lot of people who write me
think that some weird event in their
life
is going to happen and everything is
going to be better and
i i listen i'm not here to blow your
bubble
i'm here from experience because i had
the same
thing in my head when i was 23 you know
i was just bullshitting myself but
most people today these young guys these
young can it's not your fault at all
you just think something's gonna happen
you're waiting for somebody
to hook you up but listen to me you have
to assume
and i'm not trying to be negative with
you that nobody's gonna hook you up
you have to assume that nobody's gonna
come in and save you
because at the end of this [__] thing
the only thing that's gonna cross the
bridge for you
is you helping yourself and that's what
i realized
up in that rocket ship that all this
thing i was imposing on life
that you know it's it's not
the universe takes care of you life
won't take care of you it's a big
difference the universe always
takes k life won't take care you got to
take care of life
but the universe they take notes they
take notes i don't know why
and it's every thursday jimmy florentine
comes over here for dinner
he has this boy from sunday to wednesday
and he's involved and on thursday nights
i make it a habit to call him up no
matter what my wife is cooking
and i invite him off at dinner i do that
for a reason
so he's not alone on thursday nights and
i do that for another reason i'll tell
you why
and i told jimmy the other night he's
been over maybe six or seven nights
on thursday nights for dinner and i
finally told them why ago
in 1983 i was living in snowmass village
colorado
and i was working as an electrician
and every you know you work with people
hi how you doing hey mike what's going
on nothing
and one day one thing led to another
mike
said i'm going to philly and i'm like
you know mike i live
close to philly um i i take a bus i'm
like
why do you take a bus just hop with me
in the morning and then
you know just hop with me at night and
in the mornings
meet me at this place i'll pick you up
and we'll split the gas for little weak
and i was like fine with that and that's
how it started with me and this guy
and then one day he dropped me off and
he goes i can't do this today
because i gotta pick my wife up and
because i'll forget it
i'll just pick you up anyway i have my
wife in the car
and me and his wife hit it off i was a
18 year old kid
and me and his wife hit it off and then
me and him headed off
and then one night he was like hey
instead of going home do you want to go
to some nachos
at the woody creek tavern i'm like yeah
let's go down to woody creek tavern
and get some nachos and then then i went
to that
you know that was one night then another
night they said listen
my wife is making a meatloaf on saturday
do you want to come over
and i think that was like october of 83.
i got to be honest here from october of
to january 31st of
84. these people had me on for dinner
three nights a week not my roommate
they had me over for dinner they were in
their 40s
they didn't have any kids maybe they
were lonely
but they took care of me the universe
took care of me
and then let's fast forward to 95
94 93 when i was having
the roughest points in my [__] life
for that
why i was trying to get into comedy
you know i was at war with my wife i was
broke
i was living in a room smaller than this
podcast [__]
room and this includes a shower and a
kitchen
and a front door i mean it was the bed
was i had a it was a one bedroom studio
but all that was in the studio was a
[__] bed
that's all i had in the studio i lived
in that apartment
for 18 months and i didn't turn the
stove on one [__] time
not once
all i had in the [__] refrigerator
was fat [__] tired
and water and sodas that's all i had in
this refrigerator
my income was zero i had committed to
comedy
i was selling cars i was doing odd jobs
i was
[__] there was one job i did where
the guy would call me like twice a week
and i would have to what's that [__]
when you [__]
go over a tile when you have to grab
oh my god i think that's the beginning
of my [__] knee pain
from grouting [__] tile oh
but i didn't i worked for him two days a
week
i [__] sold [__] neon you know i
didn't
i did whatever the [__] i could from 93
to 95
and i got a job in the sports bank
service and that made me a little bit of
money that really i'm not gonna lie to
you that caught me up
that caught me up with attorneys that
caught me up with child support
that caught me up in a lot of things
who's selling sports information on the
phone
which i'm [__] good at you know i'm
saying i'm not gonna lie to you about
that
um and there was a couple there his name
his name was sammy he had been ace
freely's assistant
for like three years and connecticut
moved to boulder with a woman
uh she was a chinese woman i called the
white powder ma
she was cool as [__] uh family owned
chinese restaurants in
boston and i friended them
you know and they knew i was in a low
spot in my life i
i was single i was a junkie
uh you know i was at war with my wife
i was kind of brokenhearted i was
frustrated
because all i really wanted to do was
comedy that's all i wanted to do
and i wasn't at that level yet but i was
out there every night
and they found out about this and they
would drive me to gig
sammy had porsches he was a porsche
collector
and we worked together and he would
drive me to all these every time i had a
you know i had so many [__] aces but
this guy would drive me to gigs
drive many gigs drive me to gigs and
then
forget about that three nights a week
like the other couple
they would have me or for dinner like he
would tell me at work he would come over
to me and go hey
white part of my said to bring your a
game tonight
she made you some type of chinese
[__] beef or
chinese shrimp or whatever boom
i would go over the house they'd take
care of me here's where it gets better
i got sick one time and they told me to
come over and stay in their bedroom and
they'd take care of me
and they did is even better there were
nights that they were going out
and he would come up to me at work and
say white part of my
cooked blah blah blah for you
we we need to go to a function go to the
house you know where the key is
eat and stay there and watch tv till we
get back and play with the dog
this went on three four nights a week i
remember
days when they would say to me if you're
not doing anything today
we're gonna be in denver all day come
over the house
and at that time my favorite movie was
the movie with bruce willis
and damon wayans with eddie griffin as
the [__]
dj and uh
the the the chick that was in john wick
three the black chick
penguin what's her name not jayden no
no no no she was a john wick three or
two
she she always divorces her boyfriends
and [__]
she's the light-skinned sister anyway it
doesn't really [__] matter
halle berry halle berry what was i
talking about
i don't even [__] know
but they took care of me they took care
of me every night
you know not every night three four
nights a week i was over there
if they cooked they never they never
used it against me you know what that's
like
that they would come into their house
and i'd be on that couch with a blanket
on
drinking their soda with a phone in
front of me making calls and [__]
you know many things you know how many
times they said something to me
zero you know how many times those
people from minnesota said something to
me i lived in
snowmass village zero they took care of
me
they just took care of me other than
basalt colorado i had joy and fred
brooks
every friday night joy would pick me up
take me to a house she would cook
and fred and me would watch movies till
[__] two in the morning
we'd smoke pot he didn't smoke pot i'd
smoke potty smoke his cigars
and then at [__] eight in the morning
we wake up
and he'd take me to shoot [__] guns
we go to the [__]
hardware store and buy all types of
[__] guns
and we shoot them you know so people
have always taken
care of me so when i see jimmy jimmy's
got a family
jimmy's got a great family littered all
around this area here where we live
but pretty much he's alone in this house
so on thursdays i do what life did for
me
i make them come over and i let them see
what a family is
i did the same thing with steve someone
in l.a because people get lost
and they forget what the family concept
is and i did the same thing for lee
i invited him to our home if we had
christmas birthdays whatever
you know that's what i'm trying to
become here and that's why i have
i contact those single guys
all the time because i knew what it was
this week i talked to theo
had a great conversation with him i
talked to lee every day
i checked it on dalia to make sure his
health is okay and his mind is okay
regardless of what happened at one time
we were all at the store together having
a [__] great time
and now the la comics are turning on one
another like [__] you know
i'm really happy not to be involved in
that scene no more
my heart does go out to tom segura he
took a bad fall playing basketball
broken kneecap arm my heart goes out to
him anybody knows i love thomas aguero
and it was funny because i called bert
back and he had tom in the [__] van
taking him to the hospital
so i was really concerned that i called
him back but my heart goes out to the
saguaro family
do yourself a fail with tom's giving you
tons of content
send them a message on twitter facebook
and just let them know you were thinking
about them
tom is a good [__] man i don't miss
time it's funny because last night
i was i called dean delray saturday
night
and he was opening up for bill in austin
and it was so weird he was saying he had
a great week
that friday night he had saw ron white
and rogan and red band
and and uh i gotta be honest with you
for
ten seconds i got a little little a
little bit jealous like i'm like [__]
maybe i and i was like whoa what am i
jealous about
i don't want to beat that i don't want
to be part of that
anymore like it's so weird like right
now i'm not ready to be a part of that
oh i'm still best friends with brian i
spoke to him two days ago
and joe rogan is still my brother and i
still love bill burr and dean del rey
forget about
i'll shoot a [__] for dean but
it was so funny for a minute that i was
like man
uh i'm good i'm good i don't need to be
going out chasing it i'm very good this
wednesday i'll be at vinnie's thank god
the next three wednesdays i'll be at
vinnie's
and then i also want to drop another
bomb on you
november 18th i'm having a total
[__] knee replacement so uh
i'll talk to mike and see if we're gonna
have podcasts this week
if you know anything about me me and
mike are the whip
we have podcasts every [__] week for
you we're not gonna let you down
especially over the holidays i don't
want you to be alone
and uh think about [__] before i get out
of here i want to talk to you about
something though
in that rocket ship
i learned a lot and i i flipped
i flipped my game i i really
realized that i had to be
i had to be a man it was time to be a
man
i wasn't a kid anymore it takes and guys
that's the biggest problem you'll ever
have in your 20s
is that you're waiting for the switch
to flip you don't know that that's what
should even exist
but i'm telling you it's there it's
really close to your heart
they call it a valve whatever these
[__] doctors
and the health profession calls it a
valve i call it a switch
there's a switch in your heart that's
just like an electric
electric panel board that switches
you know and that's when you decide your
life
that's when you decide that
this has to disappear for you to go this
way
you know the more you keep moving
and the more you keep bettering yourself
more shit's gonna has to disappear out
of your life
trust me i'm telling you whether it's
friends whether it's a bad girlfriend
whether it's a bad situation that you've
been going to
something you're involved with the the
higher you get
these things will just fade off you
they'll just disappear
you'll go what the [__] happened you
know it's like i don't eat peanut butter
no more
one of my biggest addictions with peanut
butter when you see me at 400 pounds and
350 the last couple years
is because every night i need to [__]
think of peanut butter i got peanut
butter upstairs i don't even look at it
no more
things just disappear from your life
after a while you don't have to
yeah you have to check them and they and
then they just disa [__] beer
bad habits disappear they'll just go
away the more good things you do
the more bad habits disappear you look
at me now and you're like joey you look
different
you know i look at those old churches my
eyelids are closed
i look 10 years [__] older you know
i had no pressure living in la i'd love
to tell you
the pressure of living and it was no
pressure the only pressure i had on was
the pressure i put on myself
to be a good comic and a good person but
that switch i'm talking about
that switch went off in that [__]
thing and that switch
led me to
that switch kept me alive believe it or
not
for close to 18 months for close to 18
months
i lived by what that switch had done
somewhere in june or july of 86 i got
weak
and i started smalling cocaine again
and that led to my arrest in 88 87
whatever but that's a complete different
thing
i'm talking about that switch
that switch has to happen when your back
is against the wall that's not gonna
happen
and again i'm not talking about putting
you against the wall and having 19
arabs get up with rifles and ask you uh
what's your last cigarette and you smoke
a cigarette put a blindfold on you when
you shoot you
no i'm not talking about that what i'm
talking about is
you
you just switch like something makes you
go okay
this is what i need i can't keep living
off these excuses
my excuse at the time was that through
some
heavenly [__] glory i was hyping guys
i i wish i was lying to you
you know 1984 was a different you know
it's like people say to you
you know ten dollars now is different
than ten dollars in 1984.
in 1984 for some reason i had this
[__] weird idea
that i was gonna walk around somebody
was just gonna give me half a million
dollars
can you believe that can you believe how
[__] stupid and [__] i was
and i it was a war that i had gone into
with my stepdad
and i kept telling him for you to get
yourself out of this war
it's going to cost you this he had no
reason to pay me this money
and he didn't but what i did was as a
human being i go you know what
i feel i have this money coming to me
he doesn't want to give it to me i feel
society's going to give it to me and if
they don't give it to me
i'm gonna rob it and that's where i got
that mentality
but no i didn't i said if i had that
money coming
that that money would come to me in some
form
at some time in my life at some time in
my life
it might not be right now when i need it
at 23
because you know i want to live the
miami advice lifestyle
i want to be on a boat with a bunch of
blondes telling lies that's what i
wanted it for at that time
but guess what man i waited out that
much
and the money did end up coming up over
the years through comedy
you know my first taco bell commercial
made me some great money
[__] like that so i made a commitment to
the universe that i was gonna try
and the universe did come through with
that [__] money for me
you know the switch turns if you're
struggling right now
i have my [__] i'll give you my word
as a man
that the switch does turn eventually one
day it just turns
and you go this is what needs to be done
i'm seeing it right now
with one of my closest friends and
somebody that you guys know
lee syed lee syed started a patreon last
week
and i've been friends with lee for eight
[__] years
and i haven't never heard him the way he
is this week
you know why because his back's against
the wall he's at home
and snowed he's living with mom like i
tell him he's in the basement
next to the [__] water heater kind of
sucker where he swings his kettlebells
he's like i'm not really in the basement
i got my own bedroom i don't give a [__]
you're gonna get your [__] little cot
and go to the basement and make yourself
pay those dues
you know and but right now that switch
is going off for him
and for you people who spoke [__] and
came up with your own assumptions about
leo i always love lee and i was more
than willing to bring
lee down here until i found out that
number one there was nothing to do down
here there ain't [__] to do mike
what do you do down here unless you want
to look at trees and [__]
if you're [__] if you're [__] 30
and you're single
there ain't nothing for you down here
there's no singles bars
there's there's nothing everything is
probably there's buffalo wild ones
you know up the corner there was nothing
forwardly here
i wanted lee's switch to turn on
this is why i did this i couldn't say
this to you publicly
because you wouldn't understand where i
was coming from i was never getting
ready to leave
i was never getting rid of lee as a
friend anything like that
it was time for lee's switch to go on
the same will happen with mike someday
mike switch has gone on
since we've met your switch has gone on
like three [__] times
because why you had kids you got kids
your switch has to go on you can't keep
telling those same stories
when you have [__] kids the kids need
to eat well guess what mama's gonna pack
up those kids and take them back to her
mama's house
and then you can hang out with your
loser buddies
and do all that dumb [__]
but if anybody i give an applaud to
because bro we all think that that
anthony robbins
or that jesus or the holy smoke is going
to touch you
and you're going to change no you're not
a switch has to go off
and once that switch goes off bro it's
[__] scary
it's [__] scary i told you last week
that most of you people are stuck
because you don't want to know who
you're going to become
but once that switch goes off and you
want to know who you want to become
it's [__] on it's real i don't know
people
where do you get your motivation from
that [__] switch
that switch is never turned off once
that switch is turned on
you'll never look for motivation you'll
tell joe diaz to go [__] himself [__]
you with your monday morning [__]
you fat
[__] i don't need you i got my own
[__] [__] going on
that's when you start waking up going
you know what i'm waking up today on a
monday morning
december 7th and somebody has to pay for
me to wake the [__] up
that's the attitude you start going if
i'm gonna wake up today
somebody's gonna [__] pay me to
[__] wake up and once you have that
[__] attitude
that's when you're [__] ready so i
know that this has slowed you down
i know that you know watching the
computer
for learning has slowed you down a
little bit
but hey you got to find ways to pick
yourself up
i'm happy you're on patreon i'm happy
you listen to the podcast
to break up your [__] week but the
answer for you is now on this [__]
computer
it's out there living your life it's out
there doing projects
it's finding who the [__] you are i had
a kid
send me an email two or three months ago
i don't know what to decide on being
and he had eight things mechanic a
plumber a janitor
an artist and i'm like just pick one
just pick one you're not gonna be able
to do two or three of them
just pick one let the switch go
off and [__] attack it that's it
nobody's going to turn the switch on for
you i'm telling you right now
your mom can't turn it on huh i'm having
a baby
the baby's going to turn the switch off
me no it wasn't
the baby's gonna be there and after you
[__] up two or five times
and your wife drops an ultimatum on you
the switch will go on by itself and my
line mic
the switch turns on you don't want
listen you want the switch to turn on
but if you're not ready for it yet i
don't want you to turn it on
you have to be ready to turn the switch
on if i were to turn that switch on an
i wouldn't be here right now i would
have died of a cocaine overdose
thank god i turned on 85 and i turned it
on and it was on
a positive side because like i said to
you my dream
was never to be [__] george calling
my dream
was just to be a good man a functioning
man
and you know somebody who's part of the
community
somebody who is on top of his [__]
life that's all i ever wanted to be
that's it and that's that it's [__]
monday december 7th
you got your phil you got your little
uncle joey we got to see
each other well what are we
[__] 18 days away from [__]
christmas
this is great this is great guys
listen this is what it is it is what it
is so what you can't go to the bar
so what you can't get together whatever
the [__] you want to do you do
you wear your mask you don't weigh your
mass the number one thing i expect from
you right now
is [__] happiness and getting through
this plowing through this
the holidays is tough enough but don't
[__] lie to yourself either
2021 ain't gonna be no [__] ain't
gonna be no [__] parade on the
streets
2021 is gonna be a more of a struggle
than this
it's december and we're struggling what
do you think january's gonna change
march is gonna change april oh well
fires is coming out
it's all great there's still going to be
a mental residue left over
i don't want you [__] to be
caught up with that mental residue
get rid of it right now we got to start
[__] rocking it right
now that's why we're starting with the
lucy gum
that's why we're starting with the
[__] with the on it with the [__]
uh alpha brain i want you to start on it
right now
you're not gonna wait till december 31st
to make your new [__] thing you're
starting today
that's [__] it and that's it and
that's that i love you [__]
thank you for watching wednesday night
uncle vinnie's
i have not heard anything from ozzy's
boneyard
but for you patreon people
the shirts are coming as you can see
there's your little [__] uh mind that
joey d
is lighter and whatnot everything is
coming i love you [__] have a
great monday
have a great [__] day don't let
nobody [__] stop you
get your notebook start journaling i
don't know if you've noticed on facebook
lately
they're advertising all these [__]
journals to how to [__] journal on
how to be
whatever don't say i haven't been
talking about journaling
they're all a bunch of copycat
[__] don't pay for their
journals
all you need is a notebook to pull your
own creativity out
i love you [__] i want to thank
honey
and i want to thank [__] lucy co
again
and i want to thank you guys for being
part of uh
uncle joey's joint that's it and that's
that
have a great day and we'll see you
[__] wednesday
i wanna thank you [__] for
listening to my ear beating today
i'm sorry i just got to get it out it's
the beginning of the month
we're coming on a new [__] year and i
want you guys to understand what the
[__] is really crack-a-lacking
before i get out of here listen uncle
joey's joint
is brought to you by lucy nicotine gum
i know how tough it is to quit smoking
especially when you smoke brief for me i
like smoking a cigarette
and then you follow with a reefer hit
and everything's beautiful but i can't
do that no more i got health issues so i
had to stop smoking cigarettes
and i quit and i still [__] uh
mess around with the nicotine gum the
nicotine gum of choice is lucy nicotine
gum
why because when you're craving the
smoke you just need a little something
to satisfy the habit
it's a program to quit smoking you're
just not gonna [__] quit overnight
you people
i had a friend who tried to quit three
days later he was [__] green from the
gilts
but let's forget about all that i love
lucy
you step outside you take a moment you
pop this [__] in your mouth
and you're as good as new jack it's 20
20. it's rough out there
and 20 21 ain't going to be no [__]
easier all you people are like oh
i can't wait for 2021 we think coke is
gonna disappear on the first
go [__] yourself but you need to quit
smoking
so get lucy today so you're prepared
when you get that itch
keep it on you when your craving hits
and subscribe
so you have it when you need it lucy gum
tastes
[__] tremendous it comes in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate and they also
got a cherry ice flavored
lozenge that will make your [__]
[__] hairs blow up all right
my favorite i'm going with the
pomegranate
it's smooth you know it tastes delicious
and it satisfies the [__] craving
okay
so what i want you to do is this to the
uncle joey joy
family if you're looking to quit smoking
and you're serious about it
go to lucy.com and use promo code joey
to get 20 off all their products
including the gum
and the cherry ice lozenger that's lucy
dot co
use promo code joey at checkout
also i gotta give you this disclaimer
the product contains nicotine derived
from tobacco
nicotine is an addictive chemical but
this is the way out right here slowly
and surely lucy nicotine gum
go to lucy.com and be sure to use promo
code joey
also the joint is brought to you
by addict listen when it comes to
supplements on it is number [__] uno
in my book
why because they have a product called
alpha brain their [__]
space [__] [__] product and if you
don't like it it don't
work for you they'll give you your money
back 100 guaranteed they don't want the
product back
you go to [__] uh a mexican joint and
the food sucks you go back today to go
[__] yourself
not on it they give you your money back
that's a company i can rely on that's
company i could trust
they have other great supplements shrimp
tax room tech immune
shoom tech sport new mood you know the
list goes
on and on the [__] coconut almond uh
bites the [__] melatonin spray
to help you get sleep at night on it is
on it that's why they call the [__]
on it
that down they're [__] making things
happen so right now you're sitting there
you're confused you got no focus
it's hard your whole life is gone start
with the alpha brain start with the
small count bottle
i don't give a [__] start with that just
give it a try
give it a week you're gonna have some
vivid [__] dreams
but you're going to have the focus that
you're looking to have to get over
what's going on right now you understand
me
we're three-quarters out the door
already but you need that extra push
just in case over the holidays
you get sentimental and they also make
great gifts
go to honor.com right now preston church
and get 10 off delivered to your house
no [__] drama i want to thank lucy.co
and the cherry and on it for sponsoring
us
but i want to thank you [__]
for taking an
hour out of your day to listen to us all
right
it's that easy have a great [__] week
and we'll be back wednesday
stay black
there you go [__]
you